yeah um I've worked at Sky News for 12
years and I'm the osin desk editor and
with me hi
I'm a digital investigator
team which has only existed for about
two years
so my job I run the osync desk you might
be wondering what it means osync stands
for open source intelligence which is
the collection and Analysis of content
and data from open sources this might be
from social media might be from other
places online we find verify and share
pictures and videos for all platforms on
Sky News later on I'm going to talk
about some geolocation examples an
investigation that I worked on and we're
going to leave you with a challenge
so the digital investigations team is
pretty unusual compared to other
specialist units both on Fleet Street
and in broadcast we were essentially put
together to deal with the evolving
nature of news that's everything from
how it spreads to how we report it and
even how we research it
so we have quite a lot of overlap with
what Adam and his desk do we also use
digital tools such as the internet
archive which is basically a website
that records snapshots of websites
across the internet so we can check any
changes we also use social media for
example to help us build up a picture of
people and understand their Networks we
do short and long form pieces that have
won awards and racked up millions of
views on YouTube broadcast on Sky TV and
we have written articles on the website
during today's presentation there may be
some graphic images so this is your
chance if you don't want to see that to
leave the room leave the live stream or
prepare to cover your eyes
we've put together a short video to show
you some of our team's work from the
last couple of years
foreign
this is the story of a massacre in
Myanmar
of at least 37 people brutally killed on
Christmas Eve
it's a busy street and broad daylight
and secret police are trying to force a
woman into their car
amid the chaos one of them reaches into
a pocket and pulls a gun
looker attempts to intervene before
being chased away at Gumball
the police who are parked up the road
arrived 20 seconds after it turns
violent
another one of the staff wearing right
gear is pulled from the Consular gate
and kicked at least three times in the
head by the protesters one of the most
senior Chinese diplomats in the UK the
consul General is now inside the
consulate
it appears to show her having coffee at
a Dubai Mall
there are face masks on the table
suggesting it has been taken recently
and an advert in the background is
promoting a movie released on the 13th
of May
following day its onboard tracker is
Switched Off its last recorded position
is here in the Black Sea but the same
ship is located in satellite imagery
stopping in sevastable porting Crimea
the peninsula that Russia invaded and
Annex back in 2014.
satellite imagery from the same day
shows it next to silos being loaded with
what analysts say is great
new analysis by the Sky News data team
shows that the number of homeless
households in England relocated outside
their home region has almost doubled
over the last three years
we found that the steepest rise was in
the East Midlands in 2019 approximately
only one in a hundred placements were
outside the region today that number is
closer to 1 in 10.
legitimate ticket holders the caught up
in the crush as the stewards are
overwhelmed along with at least six
police officers that we have counted in
this and other videos of the scene
the protesters are adapting a Sky News
analysis have found by posting shorter
clips and deliberately blurring
identities a high-stakes game of cats
and mouse with the authorities
as you can see from that reel we cover a
wide range of topics
and along that slide please this is a
graphic image we uncover we've helped to
uncover war crimes in Myanmar we've
shown the proliferation of files needed
to 3D print guns that are turning up on
the streets of Britain
and we've used satellite imagery to help
show the scale of the floods in Pakistan
this summer
now we don't have a crystal ball that
will tell you the future of news but we
can already see there are rapid changes
both good and bad
for example
citizen journalists 10 years ago used to
be just a buzzword and you counted
yourself lucky if you came across one
now they're part of the bread and butter
of breaking news reporting
citizen journalists are when it's a
normal person who finds themselves
caught up in a news event that could be
a terror attack at an extreme weather
event or something like a stampede at a
concert those people then upload text
images or video onto social media we can
get in touch with them verify what they
have and then use that as part of our
reporting which is brilliant apart from
there are some people who like to try
and get internet points likes followers
by posting fake information and
pretending they are there which is why
verification is so important and will be
something we'll talk about shortly
another aspect is that there is now so
much information online which is great
because generally that means when we go
looking for it we can find it but
there is so much information online the
haystack when we're looking for that
needle is enormous and the amount of
Noise We have to try and work through
can be intimidating
thirdly digital tools have become more
sophisticated and we actually have a
special guest for you now who is going
to help exemplify what we're talking
about
welcome Kiana Reeves
give me something
[Music]
girls
[Music]
so if you couldn't tell that's not
actually Keanu Reeves doing that I
encourage you all to go and check out
the rest of the tick tock because it
only gets weirder that was in fact a
deep fake which is the use of AI
basically to create something which you
can then put onto a video to make it
seem like that is the real person
talking it's very funny when you're
seeing celebrities Put in stupid
situations but we're actually starting
to see it impact the news agenda for
example earlier this year
you're gonna be ukraines
we saw a deep fake of President
zielinski go viral on Twitter you can
see this one isn't as sophisticated as
Keanu his head is way too big for his
body but if you're scrolling quickly you
might not notice that and what he's
saying in the video is Ukraine we're
surrendering put down our arms no one
took forward no one took responsibility
for this but the agenda behind it is
clear
so how do we tackle this both the good
and the bad we're going to talk to you
today about transparency verification
satellite images being in the right
online spaces at the right times and how
that all fits in with traditional media
reporting
so first up transparency this is
incredibly important to us because it
helps build trust with our readers and
viewers that's why as you may have
noticed during the sizzle reel we take
time to slow down videos when we're
researching we're rewinding and
rewinding watching this stuff over and
over again I appreciate people at home
don't have the time or energy to do that
so we know we've got one chance to
explain what we're trying to explain
which is why we slow it down so people
can make their minds up for themselves
it's the same reason you'll see boxes on
our work helping people know where to
concentrate in order to understand the
story
another area is verification
and I'm going to talk about that
verification is at the heart of a lot of
our work something will be posted or
shared with us and we find ways to
independently confirm that something is
what it claims to be this could be
looking at the profile that posted it it
could be the quality of the content and
whether that matches up with what that
person posts it could be geolocating it
to a specific place which is when we use
mapping tools like Google Earth finding
a match can be time consuming and
sometimes quite complex
in this example this video started being
shared online on the 25th of February
the second day of Russia's attempt to
invade Ukraine it shows a military
vehicle running over a pedestrian's car
it was shared originally on Telegram and
copied onto Twitter
a translation on the original telegram
mentioned an area the obelonsky district
this is an area about 42 square miles
big but luckily for us a large majority
of it is rural
when we start trying to locate something
as Sanya mentioned we look at it again
and again and again we freeze it and we
look for things that might help us
locate it for me on the left of our
screen here are three of the key things
that helped me firstly we've got a large
roundabout
right next to it we've got a triangular
Junction and what looks like a tram line
going through it
so using Google Maps satellites I did a
search
for tram tram stations and there we can
see in red all of the tram stations in
the area
from there it was relatively simple
following the tram line looking for our
matches eventually
I got it
and here is the matching location on the
satellite we've got our large roundabout
we can see the slight
cream area here we can see the
Triangular roundabout triangular
Junction and then the tram line going
through
we can see also actually that the shapes
look slightly different on satellites
and this is one of the challenges that
we have they're similar but they're
slightly different
um this example took me around 15
minutes but some take a lot longer
especially when we're dealing with old
satellite images and changes in
buildings and landscapes
another tool that we use is reverse
search and that is basically when you
Google something but instead of using
text you use an image you don't just
have to use Google there's a whole bunch
of other suppliers and the technology is
getting more advanced by the day we're
going to show you an example but warning
it is a graphic image
so this unfortunately shows four
children who died in the floods and it
was going viral during the Pakistan
floods this summer you can see why it
immediately pulls on your heartstrings
and makes you pay attention however when
we reverse search the image we actually
found that it was circulating at least
in 2019 if not before that meant we knew
not to include it in our coverage of the
floods no matter how compelling the
image was
next slide please
another tool we use is satellite imagery
and this is a great independent source
for us we have trusted platforms that
we're able to use and search for
ourselves but we've also developed
commercial Partnerships with other
companies who have really powerful
satellites for example this maxar image
shows kirchbridge which connects Russia
to Crimea and the level of detail we can
see in it after this explosion you can
see Scorch marks you can see where
barriers have bent from the explosion
you can see Vehicles fire all sorts of
things immediately giving us access to
incredible amounts of information
now moving on to being in the right
spaces at the right time this can mean a
number of things but for now let's just
talk about it in terms of social media
our team is constantly monitoring every
social media platform blogs forums
special websites going through that
would be a whole nother talk so let's
just focus on telegram that is an
encrypted messaging app that basically
although it's not particularly new has
become and risen to prominence as the
main stallwalk for groups who want to
organize online in theory away from
prying eyes
uh we can find all kinds of bits of
information and communities there such
as information about the Russian
military the Ukrainian military the far
right the far left to drug dealers and
conspiracy theorists
and what we do by getting into those
spaces it means that we're getting a
front row seat to what they're trying to
disseminate and it means that we can be
almost as it happens that these images
and videos are being shared with their
Community we're there and we can start
acting on it straight away
now all of this doesn't happen in
isolation we combine it with traditional
reporting skills and for me there's one
big story that it really came into its
own for
I reported on the missing Dubai princess
she's called Princess Latifah and her
father is the ruler of Dubai
I was smuggling secret messages to her
and she responded with videos in which
she claimed her father was keeping her
hostage something her father denies to
this day
it was a very difficult subject to get
sources to talk to me on so I had to
rely on Ocean as much as possible to try
and confirm details where I could and it
didn't end there for example in February
this year slide please
this image was tweeted showing the UN
Human Rights Chief Michelle bachelet
with Latifah out in public it's a clear
message she's free she's meeting with
the most important person in the world
arguably on human rights don't worry but
as Adam and I have already spoken about
we're obsessed with details so I started
scouring the back of the image and I
noticed hey what are these strange
lights or something in the background so
what I did I looked at the landmarks I
found words and I was able to find it on
Google another example of geolocation
there I looked up user uploaded images
and was able to see well in February
those weird glowing things aren't there
I looked back and in November and
December they were their Christmas
lights
famously not put up in February so when
I confronted the UN they they admitted
the image posted in February had
actually been taken in November
so the final thought before I hand over
to Adam for the demo essentially digital
investigations journalists are in a race
as our tools and techniques are
improving misinformation and Bad actors
are also evolving so we all have to keep
growing and combining these skills with
old skills to continue to uncover the
truth now over to Adam for your demo
so you've heard um the broad picture of
some of our work here's a little bit
more detail about a story um that I
worked on
um
you may remember it in the Channel 27
people died
here's a little intro about what the
story is about
on the 24th of November 27 people died
when their boat capsized in the English
Channel
it was the biggest loss of life in those
Waters in recent history
just two people survived
those survivors said they waited for
help for hours in the dark and claimed
Britain and France both disagreed whose
Waters the struggling boat was in
foreign
using Marine tracking data testimony
from survivors and what authorities say
happened Sky News has learned how the
tragedy unfolded
so what's what's important to know with
this story is the actual official
investigation still hasn't happened and
this is now a year old
um so what happened the dinghy left the
French coast and it wasn't found until
the next day we used a website as I
highlighted in that video called marine
traffic
some of you may have heard of it what it
does is it large and medium boat some
small they have what's called an AIS
system automatic ID system it allows
them to be tracked and it allows them to
be seen by other boats
coordinates from the MayDay call uh one
back coordinates from the MayDay call
were sent to us very very luckily a
student was on board a fishing boat
um and was filming and doing an
interview and just while the interview
was going on the May Day call came out
and so they recorded those coordinates
and sent them directly to us so these
coordinates allowed us to build an
investigation around
and that red dot is where it is that is
in French territorial Waters but less
than a mile from British territorial
Waters and so you kind of get a sense of
where the story is going
um so
next slide please using Marine Traffic
we could see what Boats were in the area
when one of the survivors started
calling for help between 2 15 and 2 45
we know that they started calling for
help both on the French and the British
side so this is the picture at 3am and
no we don't know exactly where they are
at this point we have a French warship
we have a border Force boat Valiant and
that's the San Jacques dur a French
fishing boat which eventually Flags to
essentially make the May Day call happen
we also know that 3 45 a.m a search and
rescue helicopter was in the channel I
mean I'm not saying here that there was
any indication that they knew but calls
were being made to both sides
the image on the right is when the
MayDay call went out right in the middle
of the circle there
that whole radius is 5 miles or 4.3
nautical miles
um and it was actually the French
fishing boat which was still in that
area that flagged it up
most boats would have got that message
it was on an open channel channel five I
think is what the french fisherman told
us which means all of them would have
got it and it also we were able to show
that very few of them actually attended
the incident that helped out with the
rescue
um so we ended up publishing a story
that showed multiple failings by the
French and the British they kept passing
the buck about who was responsible for
the rescue it was clear that these
failures led to more deaths
um the full six seven minute video is on
our website and online if you want to
see more of it
um so we've shown you some of our work
the tools and methods that we use and
now probably is possibly the most fun
part we've got a challenge for you the
challenge is only on your mobile and
bear in mind we'll take some questions
as well so you might want to go away and
do this at home
um so here's a photo I took this photo
so that might give you a sense of where
it is although maybe I'm really well
traveled
um there's three parts to it where
exactly is this photo taken
part two is how far
would the two girls in the photo need to
travel
to drop off their bikes if they were
finished for the day and number three
what motorbike is the person in the
center of the pitcher riding I've just
tweeted it on my Twitter it's there if
you want to have a zoom in and look
around the image feel free to reply this
evening tomorrow whenever you get a
chance otherwise we'll take any
questions
if anybody has any
good
oh what's that microphone sorry sorry
so with the rise of content creators now
are we all journalists on the road now
question I think
journalism can mean different things to
different people to some extent
from a journalist so
you have different people that you trust
in different elements if you're coming
to Sky News you're assuming that we are
going to be and we are off-com regulated
there is a certain amount of therefore
we don't have an agenda as much as the
trolls like to say otherwise and there's
a certain variety of editorial
guidelines you know will follow
to me anyone that
records life as it happens
is a journalist but it's to what
expectations you have of that person is
how you should kind of read them that's
my opinion I actually got this slightly
wrong I predicted a few years ago maybe
five years ago now that we would be
seeing seeing every breaking news event
we go to live streamed on our phones
because that technology was being used
all over Facebook and over social media
but it hasn't quite happened that way
and I thought we would have an issue
where we would like there would be a
breaking news story we couldn't get a
camera there but and it maybe we're an
hour hour and a half away and somebody
on Facebook was live streaming it and
what we were going to do we've never
actually come across that
yeah or yeah I mean yeah exactly yeah
exactly and Tick Tock all of it so yeah
we could and I was
I was thinking that that might be more
common but actually it isn't as common
as I thought but but things are rapidly
changing it's hard to see and you know
what's really interesting is we're
having this talk now the Iranian
protests that are going on that's
somewhere that are kind of more Western
media is not really able to get into
journalists on the ground are being
prevented from reporting so all we have
do you want to call them citizen
journalists do you want to call them
content creators you've got people who
are risking their life and limb to get
these short clips out for the rest of
the world to know and who am I to say
that's not journalism
anyway
thank you guys that was really
interesting um I'm just wondering how do
you guys work with big Tech so for
example if somebody posts an image on
Twitter does Twitter share the
coordinates with you if somebody's
taking a a phone on their iPhone can
Apple share data with you in terms of
where that photo was taken do you get
the coordinates from that Etc
it's an interesting question I don't
know if you want to say that first sure
no no we've actually found the social
networks have been changing some of the
ways that they share content that's made
our lives more difficult actually I mean
I I again another prediction five years
ago but I thought that every single
tweet would be geolocatable that
everybody and it and it is but actually
the social networks have made our jobs
more difficult you can go on Instagram
and we can say that we're in Dubai but
we're actually sitting here today and so
actually I I was hoping the social
networks would have helped us but they
kind of haven't because you could be
anywhere in the world and say you're
somewhere else in the world there are a
small percentage of tweets that are
geolocated there are Snapchat
about a tiny percentage on a snap map so
we can actually see exactly where they
are but actually the social networks
haven't helped us as much as they could
have done there are companies cropping
up
that Gap so for example talk Walker is a
company that Twitter uses to monitor its
own platform and we when we were doing
some reporting actually again on the
Iranian protests we used that platform
to get a sense of the scale of hashtag
Masa amini and so they're kind of
not an Arbiter but I don't know a
friendly a friendly Bridge yeah say we
don't work with them but just some of
the ways some of the changes they've
done haven't helped us with open source
sorry is um when we when we report
anyway something to put to a social
media company we always give them a
right of reply
um just because they should have their
say in the story and I can't think of a
single example where we've brought them
something that objectively is at least
concerning and they haven't then acted
on it
for about your methodology in terms of
how you've found or tracked down where
the photo was taken do you publish that
as well whenever you're so you do okay
increasingly we're publishing our
workings actually and we found that the
interest for them is really high to show
how you work something out
um we haven't quite had like cameras
sitting behind us while we're trying to
do it but no and I do think it's a
transparency thing we're trying to show
our journalism how it works and anytime
that we do that it it does really really
well and actually you uh taking a 40
second video and making that three
minutes and explaining it in absolute
detail and showing what you spotted and
actually having that language as well
that's a bit more how you'd explain it
to people in the pub like oh yeah and I
spotted that and it was amazing and if
you zoom in and that's the kind of work
that we're trying to do what we do
sometimes do in articles
is almost a highlight of how we've
geolocated something so for example you
might have okay during the Pakistan
floods I worked on a picture that you
could see some kind of crumbled
buildings some blue roofs and the curve
of a lake or something I can't quite
remember so we had that picture in the
article next to the Google Maps image
and we just draw different colored boxes
so both blue sections were in a green
box the curve of the lake was on the air
box so you can see for yourself and you
can decide do you trust that geolocation
that we've done
any other questions
how's everyone getting on with this
um we did this in our forensics team
last week and
about 10 minutes was the average maybe a
bit longer
I I just think what you're doing is
really great and really interesting and
I wondered um in terms of Journalism
education
um is this I mean are people being
trained
um or is this sort of uh more of a
bespoke specialization within the
profession
I mean it's quite a a cool area in that
way because you don't need training to
look at Google Maps
um and actually even within our team we
have quite a variety so I'm a bit more
traditional in theory I have an
undergrad that I did a journalism
Masters at City University but actually
all the oceans skills I taught myself
off YouTube and there are some fantastic
tutorials out there and I actually got
into ocean while reporting on that
missing Dubai princess because I was
like ah I don't know how to prove this
otherwise
um and it's it's an amazing way to just
tool up anyway we but we have people who
have completely unrelated undergrads and
have never really been on a super form I
mean they've got legal training and that
kind of thing I don't know what your
training is I think I think it is
catching up slowly really really slowly
um investigations courses for journalism
but but
even when uh one of our colleagues Jack
went to the investigations course and
told them they were absolutely amazing
it was very different from what they
what they actually do so I think very
very slowly but very very similar to
Sanya most of my uh training was
self-taught and yeah playing I don't
know if anyone's heard of Geo guesser
and trying to find where you are in the
world stuff like that definitely helps
and looking more and more at locations
you do get better it's like going to the
gym the more you go to the gym the
bigger your muscles get the more you get
used to looking at images and going oh
yeah you know what that that and that
that is what I'm going to look at and
you might be completely wrong but you
might get it right your eyes definitely
do get trained at looking at images in a
different way it now really annoys my
friends because they'll be showing me a
picture of a night out and I'll be like
oh wow I can't believe the drinks were
50 off because there's a sign in the
background and that's just where I look
automatically now
I think that's all we've got time for
um we'll be hanging around for a few
more minutes if you want to come ask us
for tips on this or any
names you didn't want to share with the
audience uh we'll be happy to help you
and thank you so much for coming to
listen to us
[Applause]